I got Memegis
dare
No, I was curious about what the development department was doing.
That plan was by no means a joke, it was
all Professor Kuro Isa
's fault.  I fixed
it with a hoaxed plan, and
I was told in advance that the 5th district of the Han Chinese had properly changed the schedule of the big conference.
Are you sure
you're taking a rest efficiently? There's a
report from the change department that you haven't used
your emergency leave
.  Even if you can do your job,
Anu, if you
fail, he will be executed or washed
away.Everything has failures and mistakes.It
is a great loss to lose a truly excellent human resource
.  Rei Aoi was
quite interesting.It's proof that
you're searching for new ideas without failing to study monsters more than
usual.The important thing is that you steadily grow in your work.I
have high
expectations for the next project.  Development
[music]
Familiar number
Don't repeat it
again yeah yeah yeah
[music]